es sind spektakuläre einblicke in die
welt der kriminellen clans exklusive
aufnahmen bilder von überwachungskameras
die in einem berliner hinterhof film am
zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag spielt sich
das ganze ab eine wüste schießerei
insgesamt fallen da 21 schüsse und das
ganze spielt sich mitten in berlin ab
stehen sie hier einmal die karte von
berlin das was sie kennen im zentrum
nämlich hier das brandenburger tor die
straße unter den linden hier
eingezeichnet unser headquarter
sozusagen das bild hochhaus und dann
etwas weiter nur im süden sehen sie hier
unten den tatort das ist gerade so
berlin-kreuzberg hier in der nähe dieses
gewässers das ist der landwehrkanal hier
der tatort in der stresemannstraße
interessanterweise zufälligerweise
gegenüber der spd parteizentrale dies
also der ort dieser wüsten clan
schießerei am zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag
in den ganz frühen morgenstunden und
dank spektakulärer kamera
überwachungskamera aufnahmen lässt sich
diese tat nacht nun ganz besonders genau
rekonstruieren
ein hinterhof in berlin kreuzberg in der
stresemannstraße ganz neue spd
parteizentrale
so sieht es hier bei tageslicht aus der
ort der zum tatort wird als der rest
deutschland friedlich weihnachten feiert
hier in diesem berliner hinterhof hat
sich am zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag eine
wilde schießerei zwischen männern aus
der organisierten kriminalität ereignet
nun haben die ermittler neue
erkenntnisse darüber wie die schießerei
abgelaufen sein soll
bild liegen nun exklusiv diese aufnahmen
von überwachungskameras vor
auf den überwachungsbildern zu sehen
dieser mann cilic trägt eine pistole in
seiner rechten hand gegen 3 uhr 47 am
morgen sollen weiß akkilic ein
anstreicher der bereits 140 einträge in
der polizeiakte hat und der bruder von
clan chef arafat abou chaker
jaguczak aus diesem keller hier gekommen
sein bewaffnet mit einer machete und
einer kurzwaffe einige minuten lang
unterhalten sich die männer auf dem hof
dann geht der mann mit der pistole
zurück in den keller
und auch dieser mann ist nun vor ort
olivier v er trägt eine baseballkappe
später wird er offenbar zum haupttäter
der hauptverdächtige olivier v ein 30
jähriger italiener soll an den
bewaffneten vorbeigegangen sein mit
einer zigarette in der hand dann bleibt
er an diesem zaun hier stehen zückt eine
waffe und 5 1 kilic und abou chaker
sinken blutend zu boden
zwei weitere schüsse fallen auf einen
der am boden liegenden männer dieser
unterstand soll nun schutz bieten eine
person flüchtet sich hierhin vier mal
aber wird auf ihn geschossen der schütze
will nun den hinterausgang nutzen
doch die tür ist verschlossen der mann
mit der machete bruder von clan chef
arafat abou chaker ist verletzt kann
aber noch vom bringt seine machete legt
er nun ab greift sich stattdessen eine
am boden liegende pistole erschießt acht
mal auf den rennenden haupttäter später
wird er die pistole die voller blut ist
in die mülltonne
danach versuchen alle männer den hof zu
verlassen die polizei trifft um 42 1
bis dahin sind 21 schüsse gefallen
schwerverletzte liegen am boden einer
von ihnen muss aus dem eiskalten
landwehrkanal gezogen werden nahe des
hofs wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren